when you see a black or Latino youngster
particularly on the street you walk to
the other side he should be worried
about the fact that there is actual
thuggish behavior to not let their
children go out wearing hoodies
that's ridiculous everybody owns hoodies
well it's weird that I have to like
think about like alright man I'm going
out to this thing should I be wearing a
hoodie or should I try to wear button up
and try to not give off that vibe of
danger to anyone if I wore like like a
straight red shirt and like red shoes my
mom would not let me go out of the house
you know because she thinks that I'm
gonna be perceived as a gangbanger or
whatever I'm okay I don't assume you got
shot you know like we've worn different
articles of clothing our entire lives
and make you best
that's what a victim because of what you
wear it's different for us it's not only
just for like job interviews and stuff
like that it's going out at night it's
going to bars and stuff like that my
style is comfortable without looking
like Steve Jobs I'm not gonna walk
around wearing like a turtleneck first
time that I was really called a [ __ ]
me and a few of my boys some girls
invited us down to some high school show
now we didn't know that she is the only
black girl in this high school so we go
down to her school to see the show and
as we're sitting there watching it we
heard somebody yell who invited the
[ __ ] I was like what it can't be
talking about me I'm wearing a polo I
feel like
but the hoodie thing is an excuse you
know what I mean it's it's easier to say
it's the jacket that you weren't then
the skin color of the person I just
started wearing like baseball caps
because if I wear like I like wearing
them low if I wear a baseball cap low in
a car and we get pulled over easy it's
not even a it's not even a question I've
always had hoodies never been told I
couldn't wear one for a certain reason
I'm aware of how it may be perceived but
that's not my fault
the way this perceives has nothing to do
with who I am